طيرون اوكرانيون في الولايات المتحده
لتحديد المده التي سيستغرقها تدريبهم على
قياده المقاتلات
نشاطات ايرانيه يدعون للتظاهر في الثامن
من مارس احتجاجا على تصميم التلميذات
السلطات الموريتانيه تتعقب عناصر خطيره من
تنظيم القاعده بعد فرارهم من سجن ووسطا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر افادت
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بان واشنطن تعمل
مع الطيارين الاوكرانيين في الولايات
المتحده لتحديد المده التي سيستغرقونها في
التدرب على قياده طائرات مقاتله من طراز
اف 16 واوضحت المصادر ان طيارين اوكرانيين
يتواجدان حاليا في قاعده عسكريه في
الولايات المتحده حيث يتم اختباره
مهاراتهما في اجهزه محاكاه الطيران لمعرفه
الوقت اللازم لتعلم قياده طائرات عسكريه
امريكيه مختلفه بما في ذلك طائرات اف 16
غير ان مسؤولا عسكريا امريكيا وصف ذلك
بانه نشاط روتيني كجزء من الحوار العسكري
الامريكي مع اوكرانيا
قال رئيس الاوكراني ان قواتي كيف تخوض
معركه مؤلمه وصعبه في دومباس التي تضم
مدينه تبا وقالت في خطبه اليومي انه فخور
بشجاعه وصمود الجنود الذين يقاتلون في
ضخمه مضيفا ان هذه واحده من اصعب المعارك
وفي تصريحه خاصه للعربيه
الاوكراني المحاليل احتمال انسحاب
اوكرانيا من باخمت اذا اعتبر القاده
العسكريون انه لا يوجد اهميه استراتيجيه
من وراء المعركه
اصبحت مستحيله بسبب تواصل القصف كما قال
رئيسنا من قبل فان الجيش سيواصل الدفاع عن
بخموت كلما استطاع ذلك لكن هذا لا يعني ان
ناس سنواصل الدفاع عنها اذا لم نرى ضروره
عسكريه لاننا نكترث لحياه جنودنا اننا لن
ندافع عنها باي ثمن نحن نقاوم في بخموت
وهذا سمح لجيشنا بالدفاع عن جبهات اخرى
اما نائب وعمده بخمه الكسندر مارشنكو فقال
ان القوات الروسيه تنفذ عمليات تدمير شامل
في المدينه وان شده المعارك تسببت بتباطؤ
كبير في اجراء المدنيين من الخطوط
الاماميه للجبهات في باخموت كما اكد ان
الجيش الروسي لا يستهدفه او الاستفاده من
المدينه بعد السيطره عليها لكن هدفه
الوحيد هو تمزيقها
مدينه بخمه لا تزال عاصيه امام مرتزقه رغم
تطويقها من ثلاث جهات فباب المدينه ما زال
موصدا امام موسكو وان كان القتال في
محيطها محتدما منذ سبعه اشهر في اخر
التطورات الميدانيه نجحت فارغنر في التقدم
في الضواحي الشماليه للمدينه حيث تطوقها
من الجهات الشرقيه والشماليه والجنوبيه
لكنها لم تنجح الى الان في اختراق المحور
الغربي وادت المعارك الى تهجير سكان
المدينه التي كانت تؤوي 70000 نسمه قبل
بدايه الحرب والان لم يتبقى فيها سوى 4000
مدني يعيشون في الملاجئ في ظروف صعبه كما
ان المعارك العنيفه المستمره تسببت في
الحاق اضرار كبيره بمباني المدينه وبنيتها
التحتيه وشبكات المياه والكهرباء والغاز
الان اصبح الامر اسهل بكثير من قبل قد
تحولت قواتهم الرئيسيه الى لكن في بعض
الاحيان يحاول العدو الاعتداء على مواقعنا
في مجموعات صغيره بالمدفعيه عده مرات نحن
نعرف اهدافنا مجموعات المشاه وقاذفات
القنابل العاليه وقذائف الهاون طائراتنا
المسيره تكشفها ونستخدم الاحداثيات
للتصويب واطلاق النار
تصاعد التوتر بين بولندا والمانيا بشان
تسليح اوكرانيا بدبابات ليوبارد وقطع
الغيار الخاصه بها حيث تتهم وارسو جارتها
برلين بالتقاعصي في ارسال الدبابات الى
الجبهات الاوكرانيه
في الباحه الخلفيه لاوكرانيا يتصاعد توتر
قد يهدد جبهتها المشتعله مع روسيا بعدما
حققت تقدما ملحوظا في استعاده اراضيها
بدعم غربي التهديد ياتي بسبب الخلافات بين
المانيا وبولندا بشان تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
حيث تتهم وارسو برلين بالتقاعس في ارسال
الدبابات الى الاوكرانيين حتى وصل الامر
بوارسو للتهديد بارسال دبابات المانيه الى
جبهات دون موافقه برلين المانيا كانت اعطت
الضوء الاخضر بارسال عدد محدود من دبابات
اليوبارد لكن البولنديين يقولون ان نموذج
الاقدم الذي التزموا بارساله سيكون محدود
الاستخدام دون قطع غيار المسؤوليه
الرئيسيه تقع على عاتق المانيا المنتج
الرئيسي لتلك الدبابات
كنا نحط الجانب الالماني منذ فتره طويله
على الانضمام الى التحالف وليس فقط تسليم
الدبابات وقطع الغيار ايضا الخلاف بين
البلدين ليس جديدا اذ تحيي وارسو مطالبها
مرارا بالتعويض عما تكبدته منذ ايام
الاجتياح النازي لاراضيها تعويض تقول انه
يبلغ تريليونا وثلاثه مليارات دولار
المانيا اعتبرت نبره جارتها الحاده ليست
الا مسرحا سياسيا قبل الانتخابات المقبله
وستزول مع نهايه الانتخابات التي تكلف
الحزب الحاكمه قبضته في البلاد
قال المستشفى الالماني خلال حوار مع شبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه قال ان الغرب مستعد
لتقديم ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا بعد انتهاء
الصراع مؤكدا ان الوقت لم يحن بعد على حد
تعبره واضاف شورت بان الدول الغربيه لا
تستطيع تقرير مصير حل النزاع في اوكرانيا
مشددا على ان بلاده ستعمل باستمرار على
زياده انتاجها الدفاعي
اعربت وزاره الخرجه الروسيه عن استعداد
موسكو لمواصله الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب اذا التزمت جميع
الاطراف
بتعهداتها بدوره قلا وزير الخارجيه
التركيه مولود شاوش اوغلوبيا انقره تعمل
جاهده على تمديد اتفاق الحبوب واضافت شاوش
اوغلو بانه مناقشه مع الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو جهود تمديد الاتفاق يذكر
الاتفاق الحبوب تم توقيعه في انقره في
يونيو الماضي بواسطه امميه تركيه لفك
الحصار عن شحنات الغذاء من موانئ البحر
الاسود
دعت مجموعه من النشاطات الايرانيات الى
التظاهر في الشوارع في يوم المباراه
العالمي الذي يصادف يوم الثامن من مارس
وذلك على احتجاجي على ما وصفنه بالهجمات
الكيميائيه على مدارس التلميذات في ايران
جاء في الدعوه التي وقعتها عدد من النشطات
في ايران نطالب الجميع لاسيما النشيطين
والناشطات والعمال والطلاب نطالبهم
بالانضمام الى هذا الاحتجاج والدفاعي عن
الاطفال وحقوق الفتيات والنساء
طيب
واعتبر رئيس ايران خلال اجتماع الحكومي ان
التصميم الطالبات حلقه اخرى ممن وصفه
بالعدو لاثاره التوتر والتهويل داخل
المجتمع ونشر الخوف فيه على حد تعبيره
حالته تسميم الطالبات في ايران امتدت من
المدارس الى الجامعات مع اعلان رئيس جامعه
الاحواز للعلوم الطبيه عن تسمم اكثر من
300 طالبه جامعيه في الاحواز في مقاله
وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيدي قال ان
الاجهزه الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسمم الطالبات
في عدد من المدارس في البلاد معترفا بان
اكثر من خمسين مدرسه تشكو بعدما افاد
التقارير الاعلاميه بتساعي نطاق
الاحتجاجات بهذا الشان في اكثر من مدينه
لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان وكرمنشاه
واردبيل
تبكي الامهات في ايران على عتبات مدارس
بناتهن العالقات في صفوف الدراسه
ويصرخن لاخراجهن قبل اختناقهن بهواء مسموم
بمواد ما تزال مجهوله لكنها على حد وصف
الفتيات كريهه وتشبه رائحه فاكهه متعفنه
ومن خرجت منهن فتبدو عليهن حاله اعياء غير
مفسره والحافلات تشارك سيارات الاسعاف في
نقلهن الى المستشفيات 50 مدرسه على الاقل
تواجه ازمه تسمم باعتراف وزير الداخليه
احمد وحيدي موضحا ان صحه الطالبات تمثل
الاولويه القصوى لجميع المسؤولين ليؤكد ان
المحققين استعادوا عينات مشبوهه مكتفيا
بهاتين الكلمتين دون اي تفاصيل اخرى ليضيف
اليهما دعوه الى الهدوء متهما للعدو
بالارهاب الاعلامي هجمه كيماويه هكذا
تسميها عوائل البنات التي يلفظن سما جثا
على صدورهن يتمددن على اسره المستشفيات
وكل منهن تعاني توعكا ما بين غثيان ووهن
ودوار وسعال مضيق في التنفس اربع مئه
وعشرون ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا وصفوا في بيان
مشترك عمليه التس ميم بالعمل الاجرامي
ونقل اعلام المعارضه الايرانيه عن المتخصص
الطبي محمد رضا هاشميان ان الاشخاص
العاديين لا يمكنهم الوصول الى الغازات
التي تم استخدامها لتصميم الطلاب
اما شيرين عبادي احدى الشخصيات البارزه
المعارضه للنظام فقالت انه اذا كان هناك
اي شك حول دور النظام في مسلسل تصميم
الطالبات فقد زال هذا الشك اليوم
[موسيقى]
قال السفير الاسرائيلي لذا واشنطن مايكل
انها بلاده والولايات المتحده اقرب بكثير
من اي وقت مضى فيما يتعلق بالملف الايراني
وان ابرام اتفاق نووي مع ايران ليس خيارا
مطروحا كما اكد على ان البلدان متفقان على
ضروره التصدي لدوري ايران المزعزع
للاستقرار في المنطقه مضيفا ان هناك
اهتزازا في اسس النظام الايراني وعليهم
اعتبار ذلك في التفكير الاستراتيجي بشانه
ايران
قال مندوب روسيا لدى المنظمات الدوليه في
فيينا بخير اليانوب في حسابه على تويتر
قال ان مجلس محافظين وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه سيبدا اليوم مناقشه البرنامج
النووي الايراني وكذلك السلامه والامن
والضمانات النوويه في اوكرانيا
تطارد السلطات الموريتانيه السجناء من
مقاتلين تنظيم القاعده بعد ان فروا من سجن
وسط واقشط كانوا يدونوا او كانت تمت
ادانتهم قبل عشر سنوات بالتورط فيها هجمات
ارهابيه يوصف عناصر القاعده الفارين
بالخطيرين جدا يذكر ان اثنين من السجناء
الهاربين شاركا في هجمات على سكنات للجيش
الموريتاني خلال فتره الارهاب والمواجهه
مع التنظيم بين عامي 2011
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
تقرير امريكي يحذر من استخدام رافعات
الموانئ المصنوعه في الصين للتجسس على
الجيش الامريكي
اهلا بكم من جديد نشرت صحيفه جورنال
تقريبا يفيد بان البنتاجون يعتقد ان
الرافعات الصينيه مستخدمه في الموانئ
الامريكيه هي عباره عن ادوات تجسس واعتبر
البنتاغون ان الصين قد تكونوا تحصل على
معلومات استخباراتيه من اجهزه استشعار
موجوده في هذه الرافعات واضافت جورنال بان
80% من الرافعات في الموانئ الامريكيه هي
صينيه الصنع بسبب جودتها العاليه
وتكلفتها المنخفضه الى ذلك اعتبرت السفاره
الصينيه في واشنطن الاتهامات الامريكيه
عباره عن محاوله لعرقله التعاون التجاري
ياتي ذلك بينما اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه ان
الجيش سيزيده مخصصاته لاهداف دفاعيه مزيد
من التفاصيل عن هذه الميزانيه الضخمه في
التقرير التالي
الصين في محاوله لمواجهه تحديات من ملف
تايوان الى الوجود العسكري الامريكي قرب
حدودها قررت رفع ميزانيتها العسكريه
لحوالي 224 مليار دولار ارقام تترجم توجها
صينيا جديدا تقول بكين انه يهدف لتعزيز
دفاعاتها القتاليه على مستوى العتاد
البشري بكين خفضت اعداد الجنود بشكل حاد
خلال العقد الماضي في اطار حمله تحديث
واطفاء طابع احترافي وتحسين الانفاق يضم
الجيش حاليا مليونين وخمسه وثلاثين الف
مجند بين قوات بريه وبحريه وجويه على
مستوى العتاد النووي تمتلك الصين حوالي
350 راسا نوويا وسط اتهامات امريكيه سابقه
بنيتها زياده ترسانتها النوويه الى 1500
راس بحلول عام 2035
على مستوى الاعداد الجوي تمتلك الصين
ثلاثه حاملات طائرات تعمل اثنتان منها فقط
حاليا والثالثه في مرحله اختبار في البحر
لكنها تصطدم بعراقيل لوجسيه وتقنيه معقده
اهمها تدريب العديد من الطيارين لجانب
محاولات حديثه لتطوير سلاحها الجوي باسطول
مقاتلات حربيه
على مستوى العتاد البحري تفاخر الصين
بانها اول قوه بحريه في العالم من حيث عدد
السفن لكن اسطولها يعتمد في الغالب على
فئات سفن اصغر على مستوى القواعد الخارجيه
لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه واحده فقط في
الخارج في جيبوتي تقول انها مخصصه بشكل
اساسي لعمليات مكافحه القرصنه رغم ما
تستعرضه الصين من عتاد عسكري الا انها لا
تزال متاخره في المنافسه مع الدول الغربيه
خاصه الولايات المتحده التي تفوقها عسكريا
بمراحل
وهو ما قد يضع هدف بكين على مسافه متاخره
جدا فيما يتعلق بالدفاع عن السياده او
اعاقه تدخل الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
اظهرت لقطات كاميرات مراقبه نشرت مؤخرا
لحظه انهيار مبنى سكني في زلزال قوي
بملاطيا تركيا في السادس من فبراير الماضي
حيث تسببت قوه الزلزال في تفكك المبنى
المكون من سبعه طوابق ما اسفر عن مقتله
وفقا لمسؤولينا حكوميه
[موسيقى]
حذر مختصون اتراك من حدوث تغير ديموغرافي
كبير في البلاد بسبب موجات النزوح لعشرات
الالاف من ضحايا الزلزال فيما يفضل بعض
الفرار من الولايات المتحده الجنوبيه
المنتظره نحو مدن وسط وشمال تركيا شهدت
كثير من القرى كذلك هجره عكسيه للباحثين
عن الامان
هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن التضررا منهم من يملك وجهه
محدده ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات
الرحله الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني
رفقاتي منهن ماتوا منهم راحوا لله الامر
بس
[موسيقى]
كل جيراني في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا
الى مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت
المتصدع وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند
اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الفوا الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جولباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قرانه التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
هذا من القريه بعيد
وهسه
رجعنا على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع
الندور ما عندنا شيء
وفقا للارقام الرسميه فقد عاد اكثر من
اربعين الف سوري طواعيه الى سوريا فيما لم
يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد المنكوبين من
الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا مدن تركيه اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه باعاده اعمار الم
المتضرره سريعا لم توقف موجات النزوح الى
عشرات الالاف من المنكوبين ما يؤشر الى
حدوث تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من متاعب
الحكومه في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
[موسيقى]
في ظهور صاخب كالعاده قدم الرئيس الامريكي
سابق نفسه كمرشح رئاسي وحيدا قادر على
مواصفه بمهمته انقاذ الولايات المتحده ممن
يكرهونها
كان لدينا حزب جمهوري يحكمه غريب اطوار
ومحافظون جدد ومؤيد وعولمه ومتعصب حدود
مفتوحه واغبياء لكننا لن نعود ابدا الى
حزب بور ريان وكاراف وجيب بوش
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق ماك
بومبايو فقال ان الوقت حان لتتجاوز الامه
المرشحين المشهورين للرئاسه فيما بدا
وكانها اشاره للرئيس السابق
خلال استضافته في برنامج فوكس
ان امريكا يجب ان تتجاوز الان لحظه
المشاهير والنجوم لان الوقت حان كي تعود
الى اصولها المحافظه وحين طلب منه التوضيح
تصريحات سابقه عن مرشح المثالي للرئاسه
قال بومبيو انه وقت الجادين المفكرين
الذين لا يشوهون سمعه امريكا ولا يقضون كل
وقتهم في التفكير في تويتر
اتخذ الممثل الكوميدي كريس روك من تلقيه
صف عامه خلال حفل اوسكار العام الماضي
ماده للسخريه في حلقه كوميديه خاصه عرضت
على الهواء مباشره على منصه نتفليكس اكد
فيها انه لم يشاهد فيلم ويل الاخير لانه
كان يضرب فيه
واو
صفعه الاوسكار اوسكريه ما تزال تطن في اذن
التاريخ وكذلك الممثل الكوميدي كريس روك
هنا قرر الروك ان يفك اللعنه الصفعه
بطريقته على منصه نتفليكس التي ضربت
عصفورين بحجر واحد
باعتبارها تجرب البث المباشر لحلقه
كوميديه خاصه خرج فيها الروك عن صمته لاول
مره منذ عام
قائلا انه تلذذ برؤيه النجم والسميث يتلقى
الضربات في فيلمه الاخير ايمان سبيشن
مؤكدا انه شاهد الفيلم فقط ليشفى غنيله من
سميث وفي كل مقطع يشجع على ضربه كان يقول
اضربه مره ثانيه وثمه مكان لم تضربه فيه
[__] امك وحرقه وروك الكوميديه الخاصه هي
اول حدث تنقله نتفليكس على الهواء مباشره
حيث تختبر المنصه هذه التكنولوجيا وتفكر
في التوسع في النقل المباشر لبرامج اخرى
ووفق مصادر مطلعه وافقت نتفليكس على دفع
40 مليون دولار مقابل حلقتين كوميديتين
خاصه
اليها في عام 2016
والحلقه التي ضحك فيها الروك على سميث هي
الثانيه ضمن الاتفاق والتي اطلق عليها
الغضب الانتقائي كان قد بثها من مسرح
هيبودروم بمدينه بالتيمور
افادت تقارير او تقارير صحفيه عن تلقي
الامر هاري وزوجته ماركل دعوه لحضور
احتفال تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث واكد
التقرير ان الامير هاري وزوجته الذين سحبا
من العائله المالكه البريطانيه تلقيا
مراسلات عبر البريد الالكتروني بدعوه
للحضور الى انهما لم يقرر بعد ان كان
سيحضران
في نهايه مشاهده تذكيرهم بابرز عناوينها
طيرونا اوكرانيون في الولايات المتحده
لتحديد المده التي سيستغرقها تدريبهم على
قياده المقاتلات
نشاطات ايرانيات يدعون الى التظاهر في
الثامن من مارس احتجاجا على التصميم
التلميذات
والسلطات الموريتانيه تتعقب عناصر خطيره
من تنظيم القاعده بعد فرارهم من سجن وسط
نواكشوط
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]